6:30.
>> WE ARE BRINGING THIS INTO THE
SITUATION ROOM AND THEY PELOSI'S
FIRST PUBLIC COMMENTS ABOUT HER
HUSBAND'S RECOVERY FROM THAT
BRUTAL HAMMER ATTACK INSIDE
THEIR SAN FRANCISCO HOME.
>> IT IS WITH A GRATEFUL HART I
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE COMING
TOGETHER THIS MORNING.
USUALLY WE ARE WEDNESDAY BUT
PAUL CAME HOME YESTERDAY.
THAT ENABLES ME TO BE AT HOME
WITH ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR KIND WORDS, YOUR
PRAYERS AND YOUR GOOD WISHES FOR
PAUL.
IT IS GOING TO BE A LONG CALL
BUT HE WILL BE WELL.
IT IS TRAGIC IT HAPPENED.
NONETHELESS WE HAVE TO BE
OPTIMISTIC HE IS SURROUNDED BY
FAMILY.
SO THAT IS A WONDERFUL THING.
A POEM WRITTEN BY AHUW MONU  I
READ IT AFTER WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
I AM NOT READING THE WHOLE POEM
BUT FROM IT.
I HAVE NO OTHER COUNTRY ALTHOUGH
MAINLAND IS BURNING.
MY VEINS, MY SOUL WITH ACHING
BODY AND HUMBLE HART HERE IS MY
HOME.
I WILL NOT BE SILENT.
MY COUNTRY HAS CHANGED HER FACE.
I WILL NOT GIVE UP ON HER I FEEL
REMINDER AND SPEAK INTO HER HER
EARS UNTIL SHE OPENS HER EYES.
THAT IS AND IS REALLY POEM.
BUT IT IS A COUNTRY WE NEED TO
BRING OUR COUNTRY TOGETHER.
SO WHEN WE ARE FIGHTING THIS
FIGHT GETTING OUT THIS VOTE
LET'S DO SO WITH THE GREATEST
RESPECT FOR EVERYONE.
AGAIN, I HAVE ALWAYS SAID THAT
THE ARTS WOULD BRING US TOGETHER
THAT IS WHY I QUOTED THAT POEM.
BECAUSE WE CAN BE INSPIRED WE
CAN LAUGH, WE CAN CRY, WE CAN BE
INSPIRED WE CAN SHARE COMMON
THOUGHTS AND GROUND AND FORGET
OUR DIFFERENCES.
AND I FIND THAT TO BE THE SAVING
GRACE.
>> CNN JAMIE DINGELL HAS MORE ON
THIS.
SHE IS NOTHING IF NOT TOUGH AND
TO SEE THAT.
THIS IS ALSO BEEN SO DEVASTATING
FOR HER AND I THINK THAT COMES
THROUGH.
>> SHE IS TOUGH NORMALLY SHE IS
USUALLY EXTREMELY COMPOSED.
I THINK WE JUST SAW SOMEBODY WHO
IS VERY EMOTIONAL ESPECIALLY FOR
NANCY PELOSI.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF THINGS
SHE SAID THAT STRUCK ME SHE SAID
IT WILL BE A LONG CALL FOR HER
HUSBAND.
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN HEARING 82
YEARS OLD.
I KNOW HE IS IN GREAT HEALTH 482
BUT THIS WAS A TRAUMA.
SHE TALKED ABOUT IT BEING TRAGIC
AND OPTIMISTIC.
BUT YOU ALSO SAW THE POLITICIAN
THERE.
SHE IS GETTING READY FOR THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS NEXT WEEK.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PERHAPS GOING
TO LOSE THE HOUSE.
SHE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT BUT I THINK THE MOST
INTERESTING THING IS THIS FAMILY
HAS JUST BEEN THROUGH A HORROR.
THE MOST HORRIFIC ATTACK.
AND PAUL LUCY WAS THE PHYSICAL
VICTIM BUT THE TARGET WAS NANCY
PELOSI.
AND SHE TALKED ABOUT WE NEED TO
BRING THE COUNTRY TOGETHER.
>> AND I AM SURE THERE IS NO
WAY AROUND NOT TAKING IT
PERSONALLY.
>> CORRECT.
>> SHE SEES THIS AS A BIGGER
THING THAN THE ATTACK ON THE
COUNTRY.
AND SHE IS TALKING ABOUT TAKING
THE HIGH ROAD WHEN IT COMES TO
HOW DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT THE ELECTION ON TUESDAY.
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT HAVING
RESPECT FOR PEOPLE.
>> SHE READ THAT POEM AFTER
JANUARY 6TH.
SHE SAID LOOK, I THINK THERE IS
NO QUESTION THAT THIS WAS
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
SHE WAS THE POLITICAL TARGET OF
IT.
AND I THINK THAT WAS A
REMARKABLY COMPO